i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
battling a current infection
convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
[Music]
virus
[Music]
convalescent
all right enough of that everybody uh we
are here on
a uh very very um
what do we even call it a very confusing
friday i guess i would say donald
trump's public schedule
cancelled as far as the eye can see
because indeed he has
tested positive for coronavirus
we woke up well i woke up this morning
to any number any number of messages
from a variety of different people
saying did you hear did you hear
and indeed it is true donald trump
positive for coronavirus it has thrown
this entire presidential campaign
into a uh panic donald trump announcing
this
via twitter very late last night at
nearly 1am
eastern time hold on a second let me see
if i can get everything framed properly
for you
tonight flotus and i tested positive for
covid19
we will begin our quarantine and
recovery process immediately
we will get through this together
and this of course setting off
all sorts of calculations donald trump
announcing this
because he was tested after hope hicks
tested positive
but when it was believed that hope hicks
could well be positive
the white house determined that it was
still safe for trump to go to jersey
and to do a fundraiser i mean
irresponsibility at every level
we have clips we have videos i do have
some memes but i do want head on to
address this issue
of the possibility of a hoax here
and this being staged early let me see
if i can find my own twitter
earlier today let's go through my tweets
uh starting earlier today
um where is this uh hold on a second
okay i woke up this morning to a dozen
emails
from voters that's you people by the way
who think
getting coronavirus is an exit strategy
for trump to abandon a race he was
destined to lose is
trump covid the end of the next debate
scheduled
for 12 days from now and then in a poll
does trump really have coronavirus more
than one out of four of my twitter
followers
who chose to react to this poll
believe that it is not real
now upon thinking about this more
it's not that i don't think trump would
lie about having the virus
certainly this idea that he could claim
to have it and then claim to be
recovered and he's a big
strong boy and it could bolster he
morally he would certainly do it but i
think
even he would recognize it's just too
risky it's just too risky
to have to quarantine for 14 of the of
the 30 days that are left before the
election
and let biden run a campaign by himself
i think it's just too risky
uh i i i think even trump by that logic
wouldn't do it and in fact i tweeted
about that even for
trump logic faking kovid seems silly
if he wanted to get out of the next
debates because some people said he just
wants to get out of the debates
he could say the fake news moderators
are biased against him
and his base would buy it so i don't
think he needs to fake covid to get out
of the debates
i don't think that that is the situation
uh in in which we find ourselves now
just before we move on there was one
funny video just you know of course
listen
i i tweeted where where was it where did
i tweet that hold on
oh here it is i have people emailing me
saying they hope
trump dies of coronavirus aside from
this being completely backwards morally
trump needs to be repudiated by the vote
of the american people
to reorient the country in the right
direction i i have
never ever ever would wish illness
on anybody period and we can recognize
that the world would be better off
without trump as president without
having to take any you know pleasure in
him being sick
it is undeniable that being said that
you know people have been tweeting me
why do you care so much about trump
having it trump doesn't care about
millions having it in 211 000 dying
that's true
but i like to think that i'm better than
trump i i like to think i don't stoop to
trump's level
and that if i was in trump's position i
never would have done what he did so
that that's where i am i don't think we
gain anything and i think it's just the
wrong approach uh
uh morally as well super chats are
coming in and then i have
oh let me just play this for you guys i
really like this this was joe biden
being asked about his his behavior so to
speak
during the debate on tuesday take a
listen to this
if you did call the president a quote
cool liar
plow racist putin's puppy and the worst
president american has ever had and you
told him to shut up
do you regret any of that no
why not because everything i said was
true
[Music]
anyway okay so that's very good but this
is a serious time so we're gonna get
away from some of that
okay let me see what's on people's minds
via super chat
um chaka seki says my instincts tell me
this is real as hope hicks is a
seemingly plausible vector but i have
this creeping feeling this could be a
theatrical stunt yeah i don't think this
is a theatrical stunt
diddy miss says is trump getting the
virus the october surprise
again i don't think so i don't think so
zachary says canada and eu have begun a
review of the oxford vaccine dr william
fogg said today the first doses
are a couple weeks away in the u.s if
all goes well
that's good news a ritual
says can we at least all agree hope
hicks is hot with or without corona
sure sure we can do that azeem abu
khalil says are you aware of greg
abbott's obscene last-minute statewide
implementation of voter suppression
mandates
we will be covering that next week this
is the trump corona stream
uh ray m is calling me the people's
choice despite misspelling my last
name jonas says hello from sweden
ken says trump brought this all on
himself hope he enjoys
paid time off and socialized white house
health care
yeah let me i have so many things here
i'm going to start closing things out as
we go through them because i just have
so much to go over
um we'll we'll look at these things one
by one
okay fox news is demanding that
biden suspend his campaign for 14 days
and
the question came up on cnn should biden
stop his campaign
why on earth would biden stop
campaigning
because trump hasn't followed the
guidelines
and trump has had corona rallies and
trump
got himself sick what we're gonna punish
joe biden
remember we'll have clips trump laughed
at biden for wearing a big mask
trump laughed at biden for not having a
lot of people at his events
trump had these rallies trump showed
total disregard so
you don't have to wish ill on trump to
recognize it but
biden's done everything right biden's
adhered
as i say in this tweet by wait hold on
what tweet here it is
why would biden stop campaigning biden
is following the cdc
guidelines so it's it's absolutely and
completely outrageous biden should not
stop
campaigning for a second uh okay how
serious of a case does donald trump have
trump uh saying he tweeted positive uh
to uh tweeting that he tested positive
let me see where i have that uh
wait a second ryan okay here is larry
kudlow i haven't listened to this yet so
i don't know if he's drunk
uh here's larry kudlow saying that this
is a
a very moderate case now usually
moderate means
you know not light and not not heavy but
let's listen to what larry kudlow said
please pass my regards can you tell us
how they are doing
at this hour i will pass my regards and
we're all praying for them to get better
including hope hicks
including ronald mcdaniel who also was
tested positive look the reports are the
chief says
they're doing well it is a very moderate
case president was kind of barking out
orders for all of us giving us
tasks this morning to follow through
he's on the phone so
i have not seen him i last spoke to him
last evening
i have not talked to him today but
apparently he's doing just fine
all right so trump doing just fine with
coronavirus
here is donald trump of course mocking
joe biden
for wearing a mask that trump determined
to be too
big this is the debate to which he
traveled with hope hicks
who tested positive subsequently donald
trump testing positive
i don't i don't wear mess like him every
time you see him he's got a mask he
could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
i don't have i don't wear mess like him
every time you see him he's got a mask
he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen okay so
there are two run-throughs of donald
trump
again ridiculing joe biden for adhering
to the guidelines
there's an article from vanity fair i
believe this had some notes in it
about what is going on at the white
house let's take a look
no one knows where this is going to go
pandemonium
inside the white house as trump
contracts covet 19. this is by great
gabriel sherman excellent investigative
reporter
the president has a cough and a fever
the first lady is said to be
asymptomatic the real question is how
bad it gets and how the election unfolds
it's as if the campaign ended yesterday
says a former west wing official
is there a debate in 13 days
is there any way that trump debates in
13 days
given that he tested positive
technically today
um i i don't see how you do it i don't
see how you do it and and
it wouldn't be shocking if they claim
some total recovery and negative tests
or even you know he got he took hydroxy
he injected bleach he drank
alcohol you know isopropyl whatever um i
i don't i just don't see how debate
number two happens
i don't even know about debate number
three do they do zoom
i mean i just i just don't see it um
gabriel sherman pointing out the biggest
unknown is the state of the president's
health
this morning the new york times reported
that trump is exhibiting
cold-like symptoms two republicans in
close contact with the white house told
me that trump's symptoms have included
a cough and fever melania is said to be
asymptomatic they are worried about the
president because of his age
sources said trump will likely want to
be seen in public as soon as possible to
blunt the narrative
that he is sidelined by the virus he
spent six months down playing well
that's the truth
that's the truth he's going to want to
get out there a lot sooner than people
think
but it will be hard to hide if he's sick
also who will want to be in a room with
him
his supporters will go in a room with
him guys you know that that is not going
to be the issue if donald trump does not
uh have have events um then it
is certainly oh wait a second i'm
getting i'm getting notified that trump
is being taken to the hospital right now
hold on a second this could be getting
uh breaking trump will head uh oh
uh oh guys this could be getting this
could be getting actually serious
very very quickly uh live
update oh my god this is just toxic live
update trump expected to head to walter
reed after
positive test biden tests negative
president trump is expected to be taken
to walter reed medical center friday
afternoon according to two officials
less than 24 hours after testing
positive
earlier today white house chief of staff
mark meadows told reporters trump is
experiencing mild symptoms
after he and first lady melania trump
tested positive
the first lady said on twitter that she
too has mild symptoms but is overall
feeling good
trump will postpone or make virtual all
of his previously scheduled campaign
events
his campaign manager said friday
democratic nominee joe biden's campaign
announced that biden and his wife jill
biden have both
tested negative for the corona
virus uh update from just one minute ago
trump expected to travel to walter reed
out of an abundance of caution
listen we can't believe anything trump
trump could need a resp uh a ventilator
right now
and this is what they would be saying
i'm not saying he needs one i'm just
saying they lie
all the time uh and again
fair question in the chat from terry
berry why do you go to the hospital for
mild symptoms
they claim the visit is out of an
abundance of caution
saying he may be there for several days
guys listen it's the president so i
guess the protocol is different
do you do you go to the hospital for
several days if you're fine
i i really don't know i mean we're
getting i'm getting all of this
information as you as you get it
uh they did it for boris johnson as well
to be protective
it's because it's the president fair
fair that that's totally reasonable
uh trump spent friday working and making
calls from the residents plans to
continue working from the hospital
walter reed has an executive office
suite set up for this very purpose
imagine that including both a residence
and an office space
the official stress trump is not
seriously ill but because of his age as
well as other risk factors
he and aides decided to take this
additional step
he is expected to travel there on marine
one and walk out to the hospital
to the helicopter on his own
white house press secretary maggie nanny
shared an update as of this afternoon
the president remains fatigued but in
good spirits
he's being evaluated by a team of
experts and together we'll be making
recommendations to the president and
first
lady i would love to see if we can get
if if we are going to have video of
trump heading out
uh does anybody know
where who who might be live at the white
house with such
video if people can tell me maybe we
that's something we would be able to see
trump walter read live
um and let's see if we have anything
live they're probably blocking press
yeah
you're probably right you're probably
right about that
um okay well we it doesn't appear that
that's something we're able to pull up
but
if you're able to find it then oh msnbc
msnbc i don't think that i have a live
feed of msnbc on youtube
nbc news now oh here it is trump being
flown
now to walter reed what kind of spread
is there right now
between folks that have been on capitol
hill over there
okay wow this listen this
feels like it's escalating we're gonna
update the stream title
uh
well hold on a second this is not uh
that's that's not working
uh donald trump i guess we're saying
what uh
donald trump in
hospital with coronavirus i guess is the
um sort of most uh most
most neutral way to say it i guess
here is marine one arriving at the white
house
donald trump reportedly out of an
abundance of caution
being taken to walter reed medical
center where he is expected to remain
for several days is the latest news
let me see uh man a lot is happening at
once
i it yes uh it is true that i had a
negative coronavirus test yesterday i
will be telling you about that
if people i mean i just i've been having
some allergy like symptoms and my doctor
said let's just
you know before we start sending you
around for allergy tests let's
make sure it's not covered i did get the
nasopharyngeal swab
wednesday afternoon and i did very very
early this morning
get a a negative test that is all true i
i'm not hiding that from anybody
mentioned it on my
uh video that i did about it today um
okay so as we as we await donald trump
here
uh let me see what else we want to look
at i see people signing up on twitch i
see people gifting subscriptions on
twitch i really do appreciate that
i see super chats coming in via youtube
um
what are people saying satu gustafson
says do i think
trump will benefit from this in the
election i really don't
i really don't i think that you know
there's nobody anybody who's stupid
enough
to vote for trump because he recovers is
already voting for trump
do you guys understand what i'm saying
if you would be
if you make decisions on voting on
things as ridiculous as
if trump recovered then i should vote
for him you're already a trump voter
right so that's not going to change
and um there's a risk that trump can't
campaign
anymore listen there's a risk trump dies
this is this is serious this is not a
hoax so i think that
this does not help trump i think this
does not help trump
michael scott matthews asks whether
trump is still calling this the kung flu
i don't think so i don't think so this
has gotten very very real
very very quickly um
stephen garman says why is he getting
experimental drugs for a mild case i've
not read he's getting experimental drugs
all we know so far is that the president
is being flown to walter reed medical
center
after testing positive uh and reportedly
continuing to exhibit
mild symptoms and we apparently will see
uh the president come out to the
helicopter
uh what else do we have okay let me
just thank a few people who have grabbed
website memberships
jan's enzo christensen is new member
number one
on my website steve mcdonald is new
member number two
cameron hutchinson is number three
and i guess that's it okay thank you
guys
i i do appreciate that um
it almost looks like they've
deliberately parked marine one
to block the view of trump you guys tell
me if you think that that is that's
what's taking place here but it
certainly seems
that that is maybe what is going on
super chats are continuing to come in
and i'm glad to keep
answering them uh
hold on a second
uh where is this
okay people telling me he's going to
walter reed indeed trump flown to walter
reed wow a lot of super chats about that
david belski says it's shakespeare greek
tragedy and the bible all in one filthy
story
jason thomas says if there was no test
trump wouldn't have coveted 19.
okay um all right a lot of people
telling me about donald trump's
eventual travel to walter reed here
jimin says why should we care he cared
nothing for 206 000 americans it is what
it is
well we should oh no don't tell me we're
losing the feed from msnbc
there we go okay we we're better people
than trump that's why we actually care
about the suffering of others
uh that's it's actually it's actually
quite simple
um eric lamont says don't believe it's
mild white house doctor yesterday said
they would
convalesce at the white house well that
is changing
donald trump being sent to walter reed
momentarily
jamie says look at jim acosta's twitter
okay i'm not going to um i'll read it to
you i won't
switch off of this so that we don't miss
what may be happening
um
okay trump out of abundance of
this is jim acosta from cnn trump out of
abundance of caution will be working out
of offices at walter reed hospital for
the next few days
you know what it it really could be that
trump is okay
but what they want to avoid is if trump
gets worse in two days
him having to do this walk in front of
the cameras
in much worse condition it could be
preemptive in that sense
um jim acosta adds more from the white
house on his trip to walter reed
trump remains in good spirits has mild
symptoms
and has been working throughout the day
um that's all i'm seeing
from jim acosta oh jim acosta says
trump received a single 8 gram dose of
regeneron's
polyclonal antibody cocktail
per a letter from donald trump's
um
okay and apparently the rest of trump's
family so far
have tested negative all right i
appreciate you guys keeping me updated
on uh
where where to look for some of the
latest breaking news if you're just
joining us
president donald trump as you can see a
lot of
masks now at the white house although
i'm still reading the policy will not be
mask mandatory i'll get to that
donald trump is being flown to walter
reed medical
center out of an abundance of caution
reportedly
not because his symptoms are severe but
because
i guess because it's the president of
the united states
donald trump does have a number of
comorbidities
uh donald trump from a cardiovascular
standpoint is not particularly healthy
he claims to weigh 239 pounds that's a
number that many of us
have questioned and anything above 239
would make trump obese uh from a
technical standpoint
and that is a significant significant
comorbidity
uh trump not uh does not eat a
particularly healthy diet and he is
in his mid 70s so um apparently out of
an abundance of caution
donald trump will be flown to walter
reed
medical center i do want to say thanks
to carol hofstet who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and is supporting
the stream and the show i really
appreciate that carol
as we are all learning very much
together what it is that is going on
right now
um let's see a lot of people sending me
super chats
about trump's trip to the hospital
anthony says couldn't they just bring an
equipment and medical staff to the white
house if his symptoms were really as
mild as they say
that's my instinct but you know wait
i i we don't really know that uh we are
we are being lied to
certainly any of us would be reasonable
to be skeptical
that we're being told the truth given
the track record of this administration
but i don't know the answer i don't know
the answer
eriksen says did i miss miss the spanish
language announcement you made thanks
for everything david
um you didn't miss it no but
let me just say that i was not able to
stream earlier because
of pre-spanish announcement
elements that i was working on okay
let's just leave it at that
crimson overture says what will happen
if trump dies how will the election go
yeah i ha let's listen to what's going
on a lot of questions
a lot of uncertainty a lot of concern
frankly to see whether
anybody else may have been impacted by
that among those we know the tested
negative mark meadows the chief of staff
dan because scovino
the social media director and many
others but obviously given the
incubation period here one negative test
doesn't mean that you're out of the
woods lester
all right peter thank you again we're
looking at marine one on the south lawn
of the white house
so there it is so there was actually
i'll just read
i want to stay on this but there was a
very interesting post to my subreddit
about
what if the worst were to happen and
trump were to die
and i'll read this to you guys you tell
me what you think media everywhere this
is actually well written this is user
association on my subreddit you can read
this on my subreddit if you want
media everywhere is wishing the
president and melania well from one
human being
to another i wish them well too however
as a history teacher i would like to
take a more distant historical
perspective on this
trump dying in office would be the best
case scenario for his legacy
and likely for the country no chance of
him losing the election
and having to potentially be removed
from office or deal with that whole
process
no chance of the republican party having
a viable alternative by november 3rd
no chance he is wrapped up in litigation
for the rest of his life
due to all of the lawsuits and charges
he faces
when he leaves office his supporters
would view him as a martyr
even though the cognitive dissonance
even though the cognitive dissonance of
that is staggering him not taking it
seriously and then dying from it by now
we should know
that to his supporters it wouldn't
matter the republican party wouldn't
have to do
the deep introspective analysis they
need to do to survive as a party
because they would have a scapegoat for
all of their problems
the democrats would lose their scapegoat
and hopefully be forced to acknowledge
and address
so many of their own internal issues it
would invigorate the left and
emasculate the right his supporters
would certainly find another leader
but that would take time and in that
time the progressive left would have the
opportunity to use that time to their
advantage
democrats would likely squander it this
is obviously speculation
but it seems like the cleanest break for
everything right now
a very interesting post a very
interesting post
uh but as uh as iconoclism
is pointing out it sounds like a
hollywood screenwriter's logic to me
um all very very much
uh speculative of course i do want to
say
thanks to paul eckel for a very generous
100 super chat with the message keep on
the grind
pacman james auburn says right-wingers
like kelly
loffler deanna lorraine are going with
the
china gave our president coronavirus
spin
not surprising not surprising
um david jackson says won't many be
saved
from the cancelled rallies alone as a
result of trump having coronavirus
you know in a literal sense you were
probably right you're probably right
thanks to miriam pral who is new member
number five today on my website
jesper hangaras is new member number
six and david probst is number seven
also thanks to tom cole who's new member
number eight
jesse james underwood is new member
number nine today and sean boyd
is new member number 10. if you were
joining us
my thought was that we would essentially
just be discussing what happened earlier
today
related to donald trump's testing
positive for coronavirus
while we were streaming um
news broke and many of you very politely
told me
that donald trump is being taken to
walter reed medical center
and that this is reportedly all out of
an abundance of caution
he's going to be working out of walter
reed for several days
and of course when the administration
lies all the time
we question everything is it true that
trump really has almost no symptoms and
this is being done
out of an abundance of caution uh or is
this
because trump has a more serious case of
the virus or it has gotten worse in the
last two to three hours
we really just don't know let's listen a
little bit to what nbc news is reporting
potential for the white house to make a
statement here after he has admitted and
after doctors
check him in it could be a very long
night here at walter reed lester
thank you kelly we're told again it's a
precaution to take the president to the
uh military center medical center
justice correspondent pete williams
has been looking into the laws governing
what happens
when and if a president is incapacitated
again we're announcing
okay yeah we're not going to go to that
yet i do want to see abc news is also
live let's see what they're